je viens aujourd'hui renseigner sur
l'avenir de la fibre voir cantonné sur
un autre opérateur
qu'est-ce qu'on peut avoir comme fibres
et dans quel délai pour avoir des
informations sur justement ce qui va se
passer quand au débit à 51 depuis le
temps qu'on en parle et qu'on voit rien
venir
espérons que cette fois là ça va être la
bonne et puis qu'on pourra enfin avoir
du très haut débit chez nous le très
haut débit est plus qu'attendue sur
saint quentin en yvelines
pour preuve des habitants venus en
nombre à cette première réunion publique
c'est un haut débit qui n'est pas en
fibre optique jusqu'au bout mais qu'il y
à une terminaison en câble
donc il faut expliquer que ceux haut
débit là il a les mêmes compétences que
le haut débit qui va en fibre optique
jusqu'au cessez fer qui a obtenu le
réseaux câblés numericable pour
l'opérateur il s'agit d'un programme
d'investissements de 2,5 millions
d'euros
on a à peu près 7000 prises qui ont été
rénovées qui vont passer qui sont passés
à 100 mégabits et après on va les faire
passer ou un gigabit les infrastructures
sont prêtes pour le 1 gigabit c'est
simplement un sujet de systèmes
d'information on doit contacter tous les
clients pour savoir si leur box peut
supporter ou pas si elle doit être
changée ou pas une réunion publique sous
tension certains habitants ayant fait
remonter des problèmes déjà existants
sur le territoire
pour le moment ça fonctionne assez mal
que ce soit la télévision ou par
internet et ça correspond pas si vous
voulez au besoin que l'on a et à ce que
nous a proposée on est dans les 30 mégas
donc de mon temps et 5 mégas descendants
je constate que l a beaucoup qui se
plaignent par rapport à ça ils ont
beaucoup moins donc on sent un peu
privilégié le déploiement du très haut
débit est prévu jusqu'à la fin de
l'année 2017 ou début 2010 8 sur
certains secteurs